apple just announced their iphone 12
lineup
and though it's not the most
revolutionary upgrade per se
we did get a refreshing design change a
few more colors
some camera improvements and some other
nice internal technical upgrades
as well however apple did slightly up
their prices
for their regular lineup with the 6.1
inch iphone 12
coming in at 800 as opposed to the 6.1
inch iphone 11
which came in at 700 so how much does
apple make from the iphone 12
anyways
before we get started here i wanted to
make it clear
that i'm not criticizing apple for
making money or
anything like that they are a business
and
a very successful one at that i simply
find it interesting to try to puzzle
together their finances
to figure out where our money actually
goes with that being said
let's dive into your financial reports
conveniently for us
apple separates its income by sales
category which shows us that about 44
of their entire revenue comes from just
the iphone
aside from this 77.9 of their total
revenue comes from physical products
so the vast majority of their income is
indeed from physical products
of course the wearables category
including products such as the apple
watch
will likely have smaller net margins
than the iphone as they are generally a
good amount cheaper
this same thing more or less applies to
the ipad's net margins too
as they are generally cheaper than the
iphone as well
however their net margins for their
services as well as the mac
are likely higher than the iphone so
since the iphone is in the middle of
their product lineup in terms of profit
and since iphone accounts for a
significant amount of their total sales
apple's overall margins should be
roughly reflective of the numbers for
the iphone
last quarter apple pulled in a total of
46.529 billion dollars from their
products
out of which 32.693 billion was the cost
of sales
this includes all the materials used in
the production of the iphone
all the labor that goes into
manufacturing equipment costs involved
in production
utilities used in the production
facility and of course the shipping
costs
so essentially this includes the cost of
all the raw materials
involved in producing the iphone as well
as all the logistical expenses
involved in actually putting it together
and getting it to their stores
or your house and this isn't cheap for
apple
as a whopping 70.26 percent goes towards
making this happen
clearly they aren't cheaping out in this
sector
if we apply this margin to last year's
flagship model we can actually estimate
the percentage that goes towards the raw
materials
and a percentage that goes towards
logistics the iphone 11 pro max
came in at a base price of eleven
hundred dollars
so their cost of sale for the iphone
eleven pro max
was roughly seven hundred and seventy
dollars this
is the reflection model though and so
they likely had larger profit margins
meaning that their cost of sale for the
iphone 11 pro max
was likely closer to 700 last year
investopedia conducted some research
into the cost of components used in the
iphone 11 pro max
and they came up with this breakdown
which adds up to 490 dollars
and 50 cents in relation to the purchase
price of the iphone 11 pro max
the component cost is approximately 45
but considering the iphone 11 pro max's
larger profit margins
this likely comes out to about 50 for
the average iphone
meaning that about 20 goes towards labor
and
all the other logistical expenses we
previously discussed
moving on we have the cost of research
and development
apple doesn't disclose how much of their
research and development expenses
goes towards their services and how much
goes to their physical products
if we assume that it is proportional to
their revenues from products and
services respectively
approximately 3.709 billion dollars of
their 4.75
8 billion dollar research and
development expense goes towards their
products
this indicates that 7.97 percent or
about 8
of the iphone's revenue goes towards
actually developing the iphone
and finally we have one more business
cost
which is the cost of selling and
administrative expenses
this includes the cost of running all
the apple stores paying all the
employees working at apple stores
marketing and basically everything else
involved with
actually selling their products again
assuming that a proportional amount of
this cost is spread among services
and products about 3.766 billion of
their 4.831 billion dollar selling and
administrative cost
goes towards their products this again
comes out to write about eight percent
of their total product revenue
so that covers all of apple's expenses
when it comes to making
and selling their products but they do
have one more cost like all of us
which is taxes their tax bill as a
proportion of the total revenue
comes out to 3.15 percent but we can't
just proportionally spread this bill
amongst their services and their
products because income tax is a
proportion of income
not a proportion of revenue and as we
all know
services account for a disproportionate
amount of their income
so if we base their tax bill on their
relative gross profit margins
we'll see that about 61 of apple's gross
profit
is from products and the rest is from
services
considering this about 1.149 billion
of their 1.884 billion dollar tax bill
is for their product related profit
meaning that about 2.5 percent of their
product revenue
goes towards taxes at this point
generally we would have one more cost to
account for
which would be the profit for carriers
and retailers selling the iphone
however in the smartphone market this is
basically non-existent
retailers and carriers selling
smartphones get their profit from the
services they sell
and or their products in their stores so
whenever you see a discount from verizon
or at
t it's not because they were able to get
the phones for cheaper from apple
rather they're just hoping that you stay
with them long enough
for them to make back the money
considering all this
we can finally estimate the true cost of
the iphone 12 lineup
as we now know that roughly 50 goes
towards the product itself
20 percent goes towards labor and
logistics 8
goes towards research and development
another 8 goes towards selling and
administrative expenses
and finally two and a half percent goes
towards taxes
taking a look at the iphone 12 mini we
have a starting price
of seven hundred dollars out of this 350
goes towards the actual components used
in the phone and
140 goes towards labor and logistics
about 56 goes towards each research and
development
and selling an administration lastly
seventeen and a half dollars goes
towards income taxes
leaving apple with eighty dollars and
fifty cents
research and development likely doesn't
cost that much for this
iphone as apple probably just borrowed
heavily from their higher end phones
so their end of the day profit for the
iphone 12 mini
is upwards of one hundred dollars moving
on to the 800
iphone 12 these numbers are pretty
similar to the many
we have four hundred dollars for
components and one hundred and sixty
dollars for labor
and logistics sixty four dollars goes
towards each r d
and selling an administration finally
twenty dollars goes towards taxes
which leaves apple with ninety two
dollars again
r d is likely not that much for this
phone
so apple's profit on the iphone 12 is
likely right about
100 moving on to the 12 pro lineup
the entry level model comes in at 1 000
our proportions would tell us that about
goes to the phone itself and 200 goes
towards labor
and logistics meanwhile r d as well as
selling and administrative costs
clock in at 80 each and taxes is about
leaving apple with 115 dollars however
we know that for higher end models the
components themselves
don't cost proportionally more so the
cost of the iphone itself
is likely closer to 450 dollars and
this is the same case with labor and
logistics
it doesn't cost all that much more to
put together and
ship a higher end phone so that's
probably closer to 160 dollars
like the iphone 12. r d however likely
cost more
as this is where the bulk of the
research and development went
so we'll call r d about 100
as for administration and selling
expenses this
is likely lower as administration costs
aren't really going to scale
up and ask for selling expenses well
most of the people who buy the pro
series buy without much pushing from
apple
so that's likely to be cheaper as well
we'll call it 64
just like the iphone 12 this would leave
apple with 201 dollars
or right about 200 and finally
for the iphone 12 pro max our
proportions would tell us 550 dollars
for the iphone itself
220 dollars for labor and logistics 88
for r d 88 for selling an administration
and 27 and a half dollars for taxes
however if we apply the same tweaks as
we did for the regular iphone 12 pro
we get profits upwards of 250 dollars
from their flagship phone
and of course if you look at the models
with upgraded storage options
the extra cost is basically all profit
so
at the end of the day if you buy an
iphone 12 it cost
apple six hundred to seven hundred
dollars in total and they profit about
one hundred dollars
if you spring for the pro series it cost
apple about a hundred to eight hundred
fifty dollars
and apple profits two hundred to two
hundred and fifty dollars per phone
and if you add any storage just add
another ninety dollars for each level up
honestly i thought their profits would
actually be a lot higher
given their premium pricing schemes
don't get me wrong here
they're still profiting a very solid
amount especially for the tech sector
but fortunately for us it seems like a
lot of their price increases
over the last couple of years did make
its way into the phone
as opposed to apple's bottom line do you
guys think apple's profit margins are
reasonable for their base models
comment that down below also if you guys
are excited for the iphone 12 lineup to
drop
then make sure to drop a like and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari i'll see you
guys on the next one
[Music]
you